Dreams are an amazing phenomenon, and taking into consideration that you spend nearly 6 years of your life dreaming,
It is strange that we often ignore our dreams and forget them quickly.
Night after night our brains continue to work and bring us some of the most unusual and often dreamy dreams
Random images and plot. But, what are dreams?
Like many science fiction stories or films, will we ever be able to record and know what we are seeing when we dream?
You may have heard people talking about "brain waves" before, but you stopped to think
What if these waves are actual? And whether they carry information?
Are brain waves similar to radio waves? The answer is yes.
Both brain waves and radio are forms of electromagnetic radiation, waves are transmitted at light speed.
Every time you think, thousands of neurons work on the same frequency and generate a wave.
These waves fluctuate at about 10-100 cycles per second.
Radio waves on the other hand fluctuate in all parts 50, 000, 000-1000,000 times per second.
Scientists have long used this phenomenon to measure brain activity and connect the brain to electronic devices.
It allows us to know which parts of the brain are active for different activities, and likewise
Any parts of the brain are activated during the dream.
What we are saying now may seem strange, but we still barely understand why we sleep, not to mention why we dream.
Michael from the VSauce channel does a great job explaining the key theories of what we dream of.
But there are many theories, because we can not really measure or know what people are dreaming without awakening and asking.
Of course, their answers are subject to forgetfulness or mistakes. Unfortunately no existing device is allowed
We can sneak into the dreamer's mind, or there?
Despite the madness of what we say, scientists have devised a technique to do so.
This technology begins by reading the mind by scanning through the MRI, inside which simple images are displayed
It is composed of black and white pixels. The program then finds patterns of brain activity that corresponds to certain images.
For example, if the letter "T" is displayed, the program will record exactly how the brain reacted.
After enough data, completely different images were displayed, and then the program expected and recreated what people believed to be seeing
After the word "neurons" was displayed, the program created these images.
But it does not stop there, I started more studies using more complex images and started monitoring people during their sleep.
In this case, they first had to leave people in the MRI machine, which would awaken them in the middle of the dream,
And ask them quickly what they dreamed of.
Then they used thousands of images from the Internet to get the best approximation of what people saw based on a scan of their brain
After doing this for nearly 200 times with each person and entering the information into a learning algorithm, a program was used to predict and interpret their future dreams.
Although not ideal, it was clear that machine expectations were the best chance, to match the description of the dreamer.
Perhaps the most shocking is the study in which actual video footage was used.
After viewing two hours of film footage on people and analyzing brain activity, then a library of 18 million YouTube clips was used to match brain activity.
Here are the results.
On the left there are new clips that have nothing to do with the above, presented to people later,
On the right, people guessed they were watching him using M-mix YouTube clips as his relatives
All this based on brain waves!
As these programs become more and more complex, they will become closer to reality and capture our thoughts and dreams.
At this point, we may find some evidence to explain why we dream in the first place.
If you want to learn more about some other interesting and unexplained phenomena, turn to all time10's channel,
Where 10 great science lovers met YouTube staff together to try to answer some exciting questions.
It's super science cooperation, and if you're new to science visit the ASAP channel, subscribe to get more science videos weekly.
We've compiled a list of some of your favorite videos and the most popular to enjoy watching!